un truc plus grave ou parler d'un
harcèlement subi par un producteur dans
vos clients j'ai été votre producteurs
nantais peine annoncé maintenant je sais
que cette bouille je ne citerai pas non
mais en fait j'avais vraiment envie de
mais ça veut dire quoi commence à se
matérialiser ce soir celle beau passer
des messages et il regarde son très
insistants à l'appui
parfois gênant ça bouge se rapproche un
peu trop de mon visage
ouais on sentait que voilà qui voulaient
plus et en fait j'ai voulu parler de ce
sujet parce que c'est un sujet un petit
peu tabou et je suis pas trop m'exprimer
sur ça mais c'était surtout pour faire
passer un message aux jeunes filles et
de leur dire que la seule solution c'est
pas de dire oui en fait comme moi j'ai
su dire non et du coup j'ai g men et
mettez vous avez dû vous avez dû dire
adieu aux projets que vous avez avec lui
bah du coup je les crée tout seul j'ai
monté ma propre valeur de production et
j'ai produit moi même mais mairie
il vous dit voilà je vous dit ils se
croyaient propriétaires d'au moins un an
il était alors à cause du contrat il
voulait même pas me rendre d or à son
cou donc d'accord